and the pentagon moments ago being asked
about new satellite images reportedly
showing mock-ups of u.s warships
created by the chinese military for
target practice here's press secretary
john kirby just moments ago watch
you've heard the secretary talk about
this many times he holds
the prc as our number one pacing
challenge and what we're focused on
i mean i haven't seen
these images and they can speak to
what what their bombing runs look like
that's for them to speak to what i can
tell you is we're focused on developing
the capabilities the operational
concepts making sure we have the
resources and the right strategy in
place so that we can deal with the prc
as the number one pacing challenge
all right so here now former secretary
of state mike pompeo good to see you sir
as always thank you for being here thank
you martha thanks for having me on today
so these images of
u.s uh aircraft carriers warships that
are being used as target practice for
the chinese they're uncomfortable and
kind of stunning to look at but are they
unusual
no they're not terribly unusual we've
seen other nations do this before as
well
but it is always unique when it is a
real threat of the scale and size and
magnitude that the chinese communist
party presents it is different in kind
it is different in scale and the risk
martha is fundamentally different as
well look some of this may well just be
propaganda you could shoot at a square
that's roughly the same size as an
american vessel but doing it in this way
is good theater maybe internally but
also externally to send a message to the
world that the chinese communist party
is serious i i heard the pentagon speak
i hope they're right i've seen no
indication that they are prepared to
confront the chinese communist party on
these issues martha you'll remember we
saw our team pushed around in anchorage
we've watched the chinese ignore what
the administration says is their top
priority on climate change
the chinese communist party is intent on
conducting
cyber attacks across the world coercing
countries around the world we need to
take this threat seriously and
platitudes from the pentagon about this
simply aren't going to get it done and
aren't going to convince xi jinping the
leader in china to behave differently
yeah i mean even with this kind of
language that we heard from the
president on tuesday in glasgow um we
hear from the chinese government
leadership the foreign minister that you
know we're too blustery we're too
aggressive in our language but here's
president biden on tuesday watch
am i worried about an armed conflict or
some that accidentally occurring with
china
no i'm not we're not going to change our
attitude toward constitutional
international airspace international sea
lanes etc i'm not looking for i don't
anticipate there will be a need for uh
to be there be physical conflict
what do you think about that answer sir
uh i'm guessing that xi xing ping who
matters more than what i think i think
xi xingping hears that in here's
american weakness in america that talks
about pacing items i think i heard kirby
say or these are strategic competitors
this this is an adversary xi jinping
talks about this constantly about the
middle kingdom about the china dream
that what he's doing with respect to
taiwan has challenged american ways
and that we have not seen them challenge
the people of taiwan before
deterrence matters martha the way you
avoid the very conflict that president
biden spoke of is to demonstrate
resolving capacity we need to do that
not just ourselves but with our partners
in australia and japan and south korea
and india
the europeans as well when we do those
things well when we establish real
deterrents and they know that an
administration is serious about
protecting its interest this is how you
avoid conflict not just with the chinese
communist party but with the iranians
and others as well yeah i know there's a
lot of concern that post olympics in
beijing
it might be a time when we could see
china potentially attack or
become more aggressive against against
taiwan do you think that that is a time
frame that we should be worried about
and what can we do in the meantime to
try to project strength that would
prevent them from doing that
martha i do think that's concerning
he'll be at his pinnacle he'll he'll
stand on that stage at the olympics in
beijing with americans at his feet he'll
look down on the american athletes and
lord over them he'll then see that he is
in a place where the world has
recognized his greatness and i think his
own people will
sense that too so i am very concerned
about that there are so many things we
could do it could start with exerting
american economic pressure on the
chinese communist party in the way that
we did in the trump administration the
tools are available we simply need
leaders that are prepared to actually do
this there's always some risk associated
with that but if you get this wrong if
xi xingping determines that he can
continue to twist the knife and continue
to push america i can assure you he most
certainly will and that presents the
real risk of conflict they have been
building at least three new solid fueled
icbm silo fields that could contain
hundreds of new icbm silos we know that
they are aggressively building their
military capabilities and we have to be
clear-eyed about it uh thank you very
much secretary pompeo always good to see
you
yes ma'am great to see you too martha
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else